hey guys in today's world especially in
2024 nothing's changed a lot of people
continually run after pleasure so that
they can be happy or so they think they
think they'll be
happy because you see
temporary happiness pleasure is totally
different from Eternal joy and peace
those are two different things and that
is why so many people are unhappy today
you see it's a vicious cycle because the
more they want to experience pleasure
the more they crave it and they can't
get enough of it and when they don't get
it they are unhappy and then they wonder
why they are not happy in life anymore
just look at the world you see most
young people cannot even go through the
day without putting earphones into their
ears and listen music to try and make
their normal daily activities their
reality better and then when they get
back home people drink to feel better to
feel pleasure or they use drugs and most
of us today we need to have our phone in
hand to scroll down social media to be
constantly
entertained are you one of those people
who cannot enjoy the normal world the
natural world around you anymore you
need to be constantly entertained
because you're addicted to pleasure is
that you is that what you have become
and yes there is good pleasure and there
is bad pleasure but none of them can
give you lasting peace and joy which is
what you really
want and it is unfortunate but that is
also why so many Christians today do not
read their Bibles
anymore because they're addicted to
pleasure they get back home and they see
the Bible there but they just put it on
the side because they just want to have
pleasure so they choose their Hobbies or
they sit down and watch a TV series or
movie Sometimes worldly things and they
don't grow in their faith and they
wonder why they are
unhappy the spirit is willing always God
wants us to connect with him but you see
the flesh is the problem addicted to
pleasure it is
weak Proverbs 21:17 says whoever loves
pleasure will be a poor man he who loves
wine and oil will not be rich and you
know young people especially my heart
goes out to young people today because
the programs entertainment and things we
heard in the media were so
different then today today everywhere
you look there's Temptation doesn't
matter what you do or where you go it's
just Temptation everywhere so the
question is then is it possible for
young people today to overcome temp
Temptation no it is not not by yourself
it is impossible but through Christ we
can do all things Paul said to the young
Timothy in 2 Timothy
2:22 so flee youthful passions and
pursue righteousness Faith love and
peace along with those who call on the
Lord from a pure heart
so he doesn't say look at Temptation go
a little bit closer investigate it think
about it is it good or
not walk around it no he says flee
youthful passions and then what pursue
righteousness Faith love and peace and
pursue God with all your heart with a
pure heart 1 Corinthians
10:13 no temptation has overtaken you
that is not common to man God is
faithful and he will not let you be
tempted beyond your ability but with the
Temptation he will also provide the way
of Escape that you may be able to endure
it you see we have no excuses too many
Christians today have excuses all the
time but God says that he will not let
us be tempted beyond our ability and he
will provide a way of Escape
so we have no excuses we need to trust
God and resist the the cookie House of
the devil with all the Temptations It's
only there to lure you away from the
light from God and one of the worst
temptations there is for especially
men is sexual
Temptation 1 Corinthians
6:18 flee from sexual immorality every
other sin a person commits is outside
the body but the sexually immoral person
sins against his own body or do you not
know that your body is a temple of the
Holy Spirit within you whom you have
from God you are not your own for you
are bought with a price so glorify God
in your
body your body is the temple of God it
is Holy and it is not yours anymore so
do not use it for sexual sin 1
Thessalonians 4:4 that each one of you
know how to control his own body in
Holiness and
honor stay away from the things that the
natural person yearns for the sinful
worldly pleasures because you are not
from this world you are born from above
from God you have his spirit in you and
he cries out ABA father
you're a new creation if you are indeed
God's child so let your sinful desires
of pleasure die and cling to your
spiritual desires Colossians 3:5 put to
death therefore what is Earthly in you
sexual immorality impurity passion evil
desire and covetousness which is
idolatry
you need to be very careful of the
things that give you too much
pleasure because before you know it you
can get addicted to it and if that
happens you start to put it in front of
God so God is not the priority of your
life anymore and then you will never
have true joy and peace because that
comes only from God he is the God of
Peace
John 14: 27 peace I leave with you my
peace I give to you not as the world
gives do I give to you let not your
hearts be troubled neither let them be
afraid Earthly pleasure is all temporary
and what would it help you if you gain
the whole world everything that your
sinful heart desires if you get it if
you experience it and then you die
and lose your soul for all
eternity teeth nashing in hell because
of
regret eternity is a very long
time you know there was one man in the
Bible who had every pleasure known to
man everything that he could have under
the son he had
it his name is Solomon he had 600 wives
and 300 concubines that's sexual
pleasure he had riches the best clothing
the best food the best wine the best of
everything under the
sun he had everything his heart could
desire and what did he say at the end of
his life he said in Ecclesiastes 1
vanity of vanities says the preacher
vanity of vanity ities all is
Vanity how many of you can honestly say
that your
pleasures give you Eternal joy that
never
stops and who of you are crying on the
inside while you smile on the outside
with The Masque you put on in front of
others many of you know exactly what I'm
talking
about deep inside of you there's pain
sometimes you think about it sometimes
you try to ignore it because it's too
tough for you to handle to deal with and
the uncomfortable questions you don't
want to linger on it where do you come
from what will happen to you when you
die what is your
purpose something is missing in your
life and you know it the peace and
joy that you've always been searching
for you thought the new job would do it
your new relationships your new car new
clothes new this and new that but still
that true pure joy and peace is
missing there is something missing in
your
life so let me ask
you do you know
God because it is only he that can give
it to you even those of you who are very
religious
but do not have a personal relationship
with Christ are empty because Works
religion without true Faith a true
encounter and a relationship with Christ
means absolutely nothing and it will
also not save your soul in him you not
only find eternal life but also the
right kind of pleasures and through the
Holy Spirit you always continually
experience true joy and peace even in
trials and
tribulations and even for
me I was looking for that in all the
wrong places I drank a lot I went after
girls I made a lot of money nothing
could give it to me but then I found
God and I found what I was looking for
and I never knew it and this peace that
is impossible to find in this world with
temporary things things material things
you can only find it in Christ himself
and when you find it you will realize
that it almost doesn't make any sense it
surpasses all understanding how are you
able to have this continual peace and
joy after surrendering to Jesus Christ
as Lord and
Savior it is because this peace is
supernaturally
produced by God himself it comes from
him
you cannot find it in sex money your
career or even your family you cannot
find it in any material temporary thing
only in God Psalm 16:11 says you make
known to me the path of life in your
presence there is fullness of joy at
your right hand are Pleasures forever
more and Isaiah 26:3 says
you keep him in perfect peace whose mind
is stayed on you because he trusts in
you if you say you're a Christian and
you don't have this peace and joy let me
ask you have you lost your first
love because of temporary pleasure
there's things in your life that you
putting in front of
God if that's the
case how is that work working out for
you you repeat the same thing day after
day and unbelievers do the same thing
they work only for the weekend to drink
and get drunk and then they work in the
week without peace and joy again and
they do that just to be able to have the
weekend again to drink and get drunk and
a cycle repeats itself over and over
until they
die
the natural person just works to have
pleasure running chasing after pleasure
and cannot find Eternal
peace many just change alcohol with porn
drugs careers relationships and other
things the world and the sugar of this
world will bring you cancer
answer and the devil uses it to try and
lure as many people as possible with him
into hell he gives them pleasure he
makes this worldly prison cell this
amazing place the candy store that you
can just do and gratify your sinful
flesh with everything that your heart
desires and at the end you'll lose your
soul for all
eternity Solomon said vanish it are
vanities it is all vanity everything he
owned means nothing he died and it means
nothing everything you own means nothing
when you die it means nothing so it is
better to live for God and have a little
than have everything that brings you
into the fiery flames of
Hell Psalm 3 7:16 says better is the
little that the righteous has than the
abundance of many
Wicked oh taste and see that the Lord is
good when you finally live for him you
realize he is all you need because you
think that you going to have a little
and you have to sacrifice your fleshly
desires but you gain so much more not
just eternal life but also that joy and
peace and also everything you need to
accomplish God's purpose and plan for
your life he will help you he will give
it to you you gain a
father you become his
child the god of the universe is your
father and then he even gives you all
spiritual blessings while you are on
this temporary world and that far
outweighs any Earthly sinful pleasure or
possession Ephesians 1:3 bless be the
God and father of our Lord Jesus Christ
who has blessed us in Christ with every
spiritual blessing in the Heavenly
places if you still lack that peace then
draw closer to God with everything that
is in you don't waste time James 4:8
says draw near to God and He will draw
near to you cleans your hands you
Sinners and and purify your hearts you
doubl
minded come back to God if you've been
distracted by the pleasures of this
world go to God today go into your room
close the door and make your
relationship right with God and then you
will have peace and joy again Romans
14:17 for the kingdom of God is not a
matter of eating and drinking but of
righteousness and peace and joy in the
Holy
Spirit if you are a Christian but you
can't seem to stop worrying and have
anxiety and you don't have that full
that complete peace and joy in
Christ then you might not have fully
surrendered to God so please watch this
video here and it will help you
subscribe
and always remember life is short so
don't waste
yours
bye